sad that phrase borrowed from a great
man is perhaps the most fitting way to
describe a rough week Sulekha stalks so
Rachel and joshie asthma will join the
panel of deplorable z-- to discuss it as
well as why TV is dead Netflix is
killing you and book have the worst
words the worst words folks don't they
plus the mailbag I'm Michael Knowles
this is the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
generally speaking this was a rush week
for the president it was a rough week
for America now I am always hopeful I
always try to look for the bright side
of things and there is a small glimmer
in this week there's a bright side to it
which is that kim jonghwan back down so
we're not all going to get blown up by
North Korean nuclear weapons they have
backed down on their threat to send a
missile to Guam and president Trump was
getting a lot of flack for his tough
talk about North Korea he said that he
would send fire and fury on them like
the world has never seen I think was the
quote he said that he US military was
locked and loaded a North Korea and of
course people mocked him there was a
ruby was war mongering he was shooting
from the hip but it seems to have worked
North Korea's back then obviously there
were a lot of back channels that were
going on between State Department and
North Korea and also with China but all
in all seems like a great deal folks
seems like we got the art of the deal
here North Korea has released some
Western prisoners all-in-all a nice bit
of news for the week all the rest of the
news this week was absolutely durable so
for the bad news
President Trump has been attacked on all
sides on the left and the right for his
various responses to the charlottesville
attacks and the neo-nazis fighting
antiva here is the first statement that
he made but we're closely following the
terrible events unfolding in
Charlottesville Virginia we condemn in
the strongest possible terms this
egregious display of hatred bigotry and
violence on many sites on many sites now
the statement actually isn't untrue
there were many sides of culpability
here and pifo was beating people up as
they always do with these events but it
was tone-deaf and it also misses the
enormity of the difference here antifa
did their usual pepper spray beating
people up hitting people with gloves but
the neo-nazis did kill a woman and
injured 19 others so it was just a
little bit tone-deaf everybody basically
agreed he could have come out and named
the neo-nazis even named an Tifa but he
didn't do that so then he issue
a second statement to correct that as I
said on Saturday we condemn in the
strongest possible terms this egregious
display of hatred bigotry and violence
it has no place in America we must love
each other show affection for each other
and unite together in condemnation of
hatred bigotry and violence racism is
evil and those who cause violence in its
name are criminals and thugs including
the KKK neo-nazis white supremacist and
other hate groups that are repugnant to
everything we hold dear as American he
comes out he names these guys he names
the guys who threw the rally there
aren't a lot of these people by the way
their numbers do not seem to be growing
despite what you're seeing in the media
but he goes out he names and we don't
need them nobody likes the Nazis no
mainstream conservatives showed up to
this event no alt light showed up to
this event not even the people who play
around and play footsie with the old
right showed up to this thing so good he
names them he'd already acknowledged
that there was trouble on the left in
the previous statement seems like he's
done but for some reason he had to go
out and address this issue again and in
typical trumpian fashion it was a mixed
bag there was the the third statement
the press conference did start out very
well when he was attacking there was a
lying Democrat acts in the media I think
they do you know far as I'm concerned
that was a horrible horrible day wait a
minute I'm not finished
I'm not finished fake news day horrible
I'm not finished fake news so beautiful
calls them out in a way the politicians
have not done it's just glorious but he
didn't finish there he had to undo all
the good he did in that second statement
do we have it I think this blame on both
sides you must remember both sides
I think there's blame on both sides so
okay he has to go back he says he's
blame on both sides as a result of this
third statement now CEOs begin
abandoning the president advisory
councils there were two advisory
councils in particular the manufacturing
council and the strategy and Policy
Forum it just got worse and worse the
CEO of Apple Tim Cook issued a statement
said that what Trump said about the
attacks in charlottesville runs counter
to American ideals
Kenneth Fraser the CEO of Merck
criticized President Trump and of course
with President Trump he fights back so
he immediately takes to criticizing the
CEO of Merck that doesn't go very well
CEOs from a ton of different companies
who were advising Trump begin to drop
off the leaders of Pepsi IBM Blackstone
BCG NFL Under Armour everybody begins to
jump ship so president Trump preempts
them and he disbands himself those two
advisory councils and we do have to
nuance this a little bit the New York
Times which Andrew flavin rightly
acknowledges as a former newspaper the
failing New York Times had a headline
today said CEOs long avoided politics
Trump is changing the calculus
how long did CEOs been avoiding politics
I even noticed that I've noticed massive
pride month campaigns at different
companies I've noticed mandatory
diversity seminars mandatory harassment
seminars mandatory re-education seminars
I see them wading into politics all the
time they've been virtue signaling for
for a very long time but during the
Obama administration it was ratcheted up
to a new level so typical fake news from
the New York Times nevertheless they've
really waited into politics here and
appear to be jumping ship from the White
House now to make matters worse White
House chief strategist Steve Bannon
decided to call a left-leaning outlet
the American Prospect and give his
thoughts on what is going on and it's a
little unclear whether he got
scaramouche heed whether Steve Bannon
got mooched here or and didn't know that
it was an interview or if he was doing
this intentionally to leak some
information for the president it seems
to be the former it seems like this did
not go as planned but who knows you
never really know with president Trump's
administration so on the positive side
Bannon called white nationalists quote a
fringe al
woman full of losers and a collection of
clowns absolutely true he said he thinks
the media plays it up too much
and we got to help crush it also
absolutely true there are not that many
of these guys and the media love them
they love tying them to the rest of the
write possibly bad for the
administration he trash-talked his
colleagues in the same way scaramouche
II did a little less colorful language
and he undermined president Trump's
North Korea strategy
he admits on this phone call that North
Korea has us by the quill uni that if we
launch an attack on North Korea they're
going to kill a lot of people in Seoul
they're going to attack Seoul with
conventional weapons you could have a
hundred thousand people die or more so
the worst part of all of this for the
administration is that we're talking
about all of this nonsense and no policy
is getting done we're not getting tax
reform we were supposed to get that in
the summer we're not getting Obamacare
repeal which was tried and tried again
and stopped by members of the Senate and
the liberal Republicans in the Senate
instead we're talking about Confederate
monuments as if that matters at all as
if this is the the national crisis that
we need to pull down these statues that
have been up for 100 years and we're
talking about the court politics the
court intrigue who's getting fired who's
next out who's coming up and it's all
just a waste of time and now to round
out the week there has been a terrorist
attack in Barcelona we don't have a ton
of information about it yet
I assume we'll find out that it will
confirm that it was radical
Episcopalians that committed it but
until then we don't know really sad a
sad way to start the week a really sad
way to end the week and all around it's
been pretty pretty rough so now we've
got we will have to talk a little bit
about Barcelona I guess there isn't a
lot of information yet this is the first
time that there has been a terrorist
attack in a place where I have smoked a
cigar this is in Las Ramblas
a major tourist center of Spain and so
clearly it does put certain things into
perspective while we're talking about
the court intrigue here while we're
talking about Confederate monuments we
do have to wonder what is the bigger
picture what are we fighting as a
country what are the biggest threats to
our freedom and to our husbands to end
to ourselves and our families so
speaking of the bigger picture let's
widen this picture and bring on our
panel of deplorable z-- we have Zil
Rachel Flicka stalks and Josh Yasmine
so everybody is always saying Trump is
having a terrible go of it is this week
as bad for the administration as it
seems or is it fake news but no he's
probably having a rough week which was
just going so I guess money doesn't
solve everything now good I noticed that
these people out there anyone on the
free education so they can make all this
money right all this money want to make
a whole bunch of money for stuff that
they just want for free what do you need
all that money for it just goes to show
they hate people when you guys are all
success when you make all that money
that's wrong there's gonna be people
that are going to hate you too these
college professors are going to be
chaining another generation to hate you
that's a strong point you know money
can't buy happiness happiness also can't
buy money we'll have to we'll have to
consider that Fleck us how does Trump
bounce back from this um I think it's
going to be what he always does you just
got to keep bringing it work right past
the media's narrative I mentioned last
time I was in the show that I watched
miss backwards so never Trump times as
bad if you can the Chia I think you
maybe have the better people think I
think he did a great job it's bowing egg
groups on both sides what more he could
have done look if she had I think he's
got to be fit and just keep Island proof
it's a war that is right the consistency
is a real issue because he gave his
first statement which was okay
he gave the second statement naming the
people probably a little bit better and
I think give us a third statement a
backtracked on the second and creates a
lot of confusion maybe it was for DHS
Josh China seems to be cooperating with
us on trade in North Korea would you say
that there is a glimmer of hope this
week on the foreign policy front um I
think so I think that Trump has done a
good job behind the scenes but he hasn't
done a good job articulating his vision
he hasn't done a good job telling us
what he's done behind the scenes we've
had to rely on administration officials
op-eds and uh you know reporting raja
jesting the president Trump does not
have the best words I'm telling her
that's where the folks because I won't
stand for that he has a communication
problem for sure even when he does
something good he makes it seem like
it's a bad thing or he doesn't
articulate it properly that's the
problem and perception is oftentimes
reality well you know all right we've
got to get into the news I want to keep
this panel around for at least one news
story and then we'll have to say goodbye
to all of you who haven't subscribed to
the daily wire in the news today Apple
is spending 1 billion dollars a billion
with a be developing original content
Netflix is going to spend seven billion
dollars developing original content and
Facebook is even developing original TV
content though is TV did uh well it's
like just like saying rock-and-rollers
did it's like no rocket roadside ad T DS
not dead
uh but yeah I would agree that uh Deaf
culture is being promoted as I when it's
talk about this stuff is bad for say
yeah a lot of the stuff is bad words
they promote crappy messages hey if
they're gonna spend all his money and
it's funny man because I always say the
Republicans are the ones with all the
money but it looks like there was it
wasn't all money to be able to invest in
all this sub units attributive just with
somebody else's money may be great if
he's so-called
rich Republicans I'd like to find out
who they are be great if they would put
their money whatever mouth is and start
investing in some content to compete
with a full yeah this is a plea from
Hollywood if you're out there
Republicans with money
give us some TV show or movie is there
some something yes I hear Republicans
well with the money
rich Republicans like where I'm looking
for I can't find them anywhere I still I
still haven't even gotten all my book
checks yet Josh is this new all
on-demand model is it good or is it bad
for the consumer you can stay up late
you can watch whatever show you on you
watch it for a hundred hours is that
good or bad for us it's a little bit of
both I think that's a strong statement
well you're going to have to defend that
ultimately it gives consumers more
choice you know I can
go to work during the day and then come
back home at night and watch a show at
midnight if I wanted to but I think
there's something to be said about the
fact that TV in decades prior gave the
country a way to coalesce around
something it was this moment of
stillness of this collective unity where
we can all kind of put aside our
politics put aside our differences and
engage in the show and now TV watching
seems to be a solitary act it seems to
be you know individuals alone in the
rooms watching on their laptops rather
than projecting here no I think you make
a very good point because there are two
levels of is they used to be on the one
hand you've got families coming together
around a TV and watching it but they're
also with the fact that all of America
was watching the same show right there
weren't that many channels we had a
common culture flek us does this
destruction of the common culture
explain some of the crazy polarization
we're seeing yeah I would say so I mean
they're really catering to the younger
viewers who are very computer savvy very
tech savvy they want to watch these
shows in their own time I think a lot of
these people are watching to see shows
not a fairly they used to back in the
day where you should tune in every day
at 10 o'clock and your program this so I
think it heads down the tricky road
because all these companies are festive
more to these liberal outlets are now
going to be pushed to narrative on don't
the other fronts and it G really hard to
competitive that's absolutely true the
one exception might be the game of
Thrones Game of Thrones is a kind of
common thing it's always trending on
Twitter there were rumors that it leaked
did you all watch the leaked episode
well considered a game of girls and
weaking and how much nudity that just
stopped gross well that's an image that
I won't be able to spoon out of my
mind's eye unfortunately I am so glad we
don't have any criminals on our panel of
deplorable z-- but they're deplorable in
many other ways but now if you don't
subscribe to The Daily wire you can't
keep watching them we want to thank all
the subscribers who have come along with
it you can go over now to daily wire
I kind of watch the rest of the show and
if you haven't done that already go to
daily wire comm and sign up it's only
ten bucks a month 100 dollars a year you
get the leftist here's tumblr which
keeps your leftist ears hot or cold
always salty and savory and delicious
and you'll also get my show you'll get
at the end replacement show and you'll
get the bench up euro show so go over
there right now daily wire comm we'll be
right back
so I have bad news about the binge
watching TV culture according to a study
there's so many studies a new study
shows that binge watching is one series
before bed is worse for your health than
watching the same amount of regular TV
because of something called quote mental
arousal how do they know what I'm
watching Fleck us one of the negative
effects of these streaming platforms is
it's so hard to find time to read books
23% of Americans per year don't read a
single book and that rate has tripled
since 1978
are we getting dumber or is this TV all
these great TV shows are they somewhat
edifying hmm hard to say I mean I watch
a lot of Netflix I'm in great shape so
you'd make an excellent argument I think
that said on it I think that's it right
I mean I'm in pretty good shape let me
be the poster poster boy of it that
place doesn't necessarily make you not
exercise and do stuff if you sit there
and watch the entire season show on a
Sunday you know last week and I think
it's going to affect that healthy like
luck is healthy likes luck is oh science
is always scaring us with nonsense like
climate change and tobacco warning
labels do you believe this mental
arousal thing that it keeps you from
sleeping is Netflix really killing us
then it is me next concerns well I don't
think it in terms of rails at all a
sense of be also be flash and thought
but you know I wanted to say something
to a point that my man was talking about
in terms of like you know uh you know
this solitary watching you know if it's
ironic there was they talked about unity
and bringing everybody together but this
ended their promoting about this
binge-watching was it it's like there's
no unity and watching TV anymore and
people don't want to say nothing because
they get into a conversation like no
don't spoil it for me so right I'd just
be like yeah and not only that this this
if I separates the herd because now it's
like you just you don't have to uh you
know there's a push back the culture is
isolated by themselves and watching the
stuff these ideals that they're promote
their pumping into their brain and
why there's no uh no failure in numbers
anymore right yeah no filter no signet
they got to buy their sympathy just pump
their ideas into their hips like one of
the top I think it's worth man yeah we
used to watch a TV show and then that's
all anybody would talk about the next
day and now you explicitly can you can
talk about anything but that because
people are watching and on different
time tables that is true Josh you are a
degenerate when was the last time you
turned off the TV and read a book
several weeks ago actually that is
better than most Americans it is well I
was an English major so um but you know
though is right I think that there's
something unhealthy about this solitary
TV watching and I don't want to say that
you know people aren't consuming text
people aren't engaging with language
because I think the mediums are changing
I think people are reading more articles
online I think people are consuming text
on their phones I think so reading the
daily wired Act reading the daily water
Tom exactly I never stopped they never
get it off their phones exactly so I
think the the way we consume text is
changing and that's going to keep
changing but so we're on the verge of an
almost kind of like a revolution where
our own sort of printing press and the
printing press is digital media yuck I
like the old media but speaking of that
you probably right speaking of those
books and these new media a new study
uh not yet another study has found to
quote a dramatic increase in swear words
in American literature over the last 60
years books published between 2005 and
2008 were 28 more times more likely to
contain swear words than books published
in the 1950s and one study in particular
found that there was one word that was
678 times more likely to be included
I'll let you think about what that word
that was so WTF man why all the naughty
language and you know and I feel like
I'm kind of on the spot here because my
book
actually called weapon of mass
destruction and when people look for it
it's like man I tried to look up your
book I just keep running into gay porn
that was part of the strategy man it's
like to help get the liberals to get it
on their radar too somehow
but despite that I think that it's the
only profanity that is in my book and
even a SS an academic stands for
American socialist state so but yeah for
some reason people want to use profanity
to give punctuation to their point you
know it's like you know might just drop
this curse word it's gonna make my point
so much more valid and I think about you
know what went God you know spoke the
universe with this is big deep F you'd
have to say that man even let there be
light children superkicked expected
that's power yeah you don't need a curse
to be powerful yeah you don't you don't
see God using a lot of naughty language
in there there's really strong
statements in Genesis I don't know what
text you're reading I marked Marshall as
a particular Bible Josh is this a
reflection of our more shallow culture a
reflection of our thought you know David
McCullough's said that too right well is
to think clearly that's why it's so hard
is that is that what it's a reflection
of I don't know if it's a reflection of
our more shallow culture I think that
publishers are trying to attract
consumers and they're willing to do
anything to attract consumers even if
that includes profanity eroticism
there's a reason Fifty Shades of Grey
was so successful it wasn't because it
was a brilliant plot it was because you
know it was catering to a specific kind
of consumer and the character
development exactly absolutely brilliant
every challenge is absolutely no you
know that's absolutely true and you're
right though when you when you use swear
words too much they get a little watered
down you know they it's sort of like how
conservationists say we have to kill
animals so that we can preserve animals
there is an argument that we have to
stop using swear words so that we can
keep using swear words effectively Fleck
us do we need to clean up our language I
don't think so
I think this is a sign that freedom of
speech is alive and well in the US I
think this is a great thing and there's
no sup and around with the First
Amendment and no one stopping
in it and free speech is alive and well
that's what it tells me the first effing
amendment absolutely okay well on that
note I gotta say goodbye to you guys our
panel of deplorable zou Rachael flex
talks and Josh Jasna I will also note by
the way that my own book reasons to vote
for Democrats a comprehensive guide does
not include a single swear word so if
you're looking for family-friendly
reading I think we're a place to go look
okay it's time for the mailbag we have a
lot of great mailbag question so I'm
going to run through them as fast as I
can
first one from Brett dear bestselling
author mr. Knowles what advice do you
have for authors looking to write their
first book really enjoy the podcast and
the panel of deplorable thanks Brett I
have no advice for authors looking to
write their first book because I've
never written a book though I am a
number one international best-selling
author with a presidential endorsement
author not a writer it's very confusing
I would ask Andrew Clavin or her shapiro
on for any advice on writing book since
they have written them before from Jeff
hey Michael I have really enjoyed your
show and the people you have brought on
I was wondering who you have read or
listened to about your faith to help you
continue down the Catholic path on
Catholic and I really enjoy reading and
watching YouTube of Bishop Baron Peter
Crieff and Scott Hahn thanks those guys
are all great I can recommend some
people in particular my own priest in
New York who is he'll be officiating my
wedding next year his father George rut
ler rut ler is an amazing guy I've read
a lot of his books and all of his
columns in crisis magazine he writes a
weekly column and you can get his
homilies online at the Church of st.
Michael in NYC it's in Hell's Kitchen
I rarely does a Sunday go by that I
don't read them or listen to them they
are really really good he is in a really
interesting man you should look up some
biographies of him I think he was Bill
Buckley's priest he's got a long
association with the conservative
movement and people on the right and he
was a hero of 9/11 he's just a really
really amazing man and I think his
writing more than more than basically
anybody's has brought me back to the
Catholic faith and
two ecumenical Christianity writ large
so I highly recommend reading him and
then of course CS Lewis and GK
Chesterton are also great and and
unfortunately only one of those guys has
YouTube videos so you can explore them
at your leisure
from thou question hey Michael I was
wondering if you could give your opinion
on Gen Z and what the post millennial
generation might mean for the
conservative movement Thanks
I love them they are the best people
ever they are we had the greatest
generation in the 30s and 40s but
they're pretty close maybe they'll be
better I don't know they have a lot of
time and we might be going to war with
Korea or something they're great I think
my generation the Millennials grew up
and were enamored of Barack Obama I got
to college right when Obama won in 2008
and we just totally fell for this guy we
were a little soft
we were helicopter parented
participation trophies all of that from
what I know of Gen Z and the post
Millennials they are reacting to that
they I think they see the world a little
bit more clearly they cut through some
of the BS and some of the ideological
constructs that we were imbued with when
we were kids and I think they're just
great and they should keep on doing it
from Tyler question knowles of the tro
i'm sorry from tyler here's the question
yo Mike will you please answer this
phenomenal question and that's the
entire a mailbag question and the answer
is yes from Joe question Knowles of the
trolls you hear a lot of people talk a
lot of talk about how Republicans and
specifically Trump are the largest
threat to our republic these comments
typically made by people who would
rather wipe their tookus with the
Constitution however on an international
front there were threats in the rogue
regimes of North Korea and Iran
ultimately the domestic threat of seeing
the Browns versus the rezidentura
streets
strikes me as most jarring what do you
think is the largest threat to our great
nation I will read you a poem to answer
them some say the world will wind up
Nazi some say liberal fascist from what
I'm told by paparazzi I hold with those
who forecast Nazi but if it must return
to ashes I think I've read enough of
Marx to know Antipa clashes always throw
off sparks
also trashes I hope that answers your
question from Patrick question do you
think the Republican Party will move
toward libertarianism not populism or
the or rather to the left in order to
survive a lot of people ask that how are
we going to survive how are we going to
survive in this culture because the
culture is so against us we get it from
Hollywood we get it from the mainstream
press all the time we see in our
Facebook feed with hysterical lefties
but we are winning if you look at the
actual numbers we are winning so much
we're almost sick and tired of winning
we took almost a thousand seats under
Barack Obama's presidency in the state
houses we took 24 out of 32
governorships in those places with
Republican state houses where Republican
legislators rather we took the Congress
obviously we took the Senate we took the
presidency I think we're doing pretty
well between libertarianism or
conservatism or on those fringes some
people advocate white identity politics
I think what we have to do is always
refer back to human dignity and ordered
liberty if we refer back to those
foundational principles I think we can
read the American founding documents and
the American ideals through them and we
won't go wrong we've always got to stay
focused on ordered liberty and human
dignity if we do that I think we're
going to just keep on winning from coal
dear mr. Rodham Clinton Knowles I'm glad
that you could reference my cousin I
noticed when you advertise the
subscription for The Daily wire you
don't show off the leftist tears mug is
this because Ben found out that you were
related to HRC and won't let you use one
love to show my condolences to you for
being related to Hillary that is not the
reason it's actually because steven
crowder smashed my leftist here's tumblr
on his own show so said another question
from Kyle master Knowles a couple of
times on the show now I've heard rubbing
millennial mentioned that she is hoping
to have a family within five years I
think I see where this is going while I
am unsure of the status of her love life
I believe I could help her reach that
goal I am a straight white cisgender
conservative male so long as she can see
past all the privilege and unconscious
bias I innately possessed I think we
could really make it work thanks Kyle
Kyle I have said this before and I will
say it again we are auditioning rummy
millennial to become a sister-wife
once I get married to sweet little Elise
in my fiance and we start our
apocalyptic right-wing polygamous cult
she's mine hands off from James hi
Michael do you believe the alt rights
philosophy is similar to the left in
that it is somewhat of a pseudo religion
as I believe it was set on yours or
Clavin show the left prefers the essence
of something rather than the content of
that thing I think what you mean is they
prefer the appearance or the semblance
of something rather than what actually
makes it that thing what animates it I
find it quite sad to quote a great man
thanks James yeah I think they're two
sides of the same coin
I think they and I think they would
admit that too they say these identity
tactics have been working for the left
for a long time and we're going to start
doing it to this disreputable
dishonorable behavior is been working
for the left we're going to do it too so
yeah absolutely it's on the flip side of
the left I would say it's a pseudo
religion in that it is an ideology and
ideology replaces religion but it's also
pseudo philosophic you know their ideas
really don't hold together they try to
put off this image of logic and
philosophical coherence I don't think
they have any of it I think it's like
most modern art you think it must be
profound because the artist tells you
that it is but if you scratch below the
surface you realize it's a bunch of
nonsense and I think there is a
essential paradox at the heart of their
ideas which is that they defend
Christendom but they hate Christianity
and they don't practice it so I
definitely discount them as I would
discount the left and I think we should
disregard all of that and just read some
books man and defend Western
civilization and culture in a serious
way and in a way that will lead us
toward more ordered liberty and human
dignity and more winning winning winning
okay that's enough it was a rough week
we will be back tomorrow join us
hopefully it will be a better oh I'm
sorry we'll be back on Monday hopefully
it will be a better week and you can
survive the weekend I'm Michael Knowles
this is the Michael Noel's show thank
you for watching
you
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
pond5
[Music]